I urge a busy house how's the cash life
young women and my baby live the nearest
hard man know if I can't do with you do
really right there you played okay my
weight you're gonna be so ruthless clips
and legacy changes you think you won't
change the situation would you take you
just hit that first be hard are you
closing down the street all right losing
them in my six [ __ ] and I was doping you
listen the to competence very own ice
cube eazy-e and dr. Dre I gotta tell you
you are witnessing history different
stereotypes you have a unique hoist the
world needs to hear they want nw8 let's
kill them in w-wait
this is only the tip of the iceberg
gentlemen what's going on what do you
have in that bag
this song's glamorize gang robbed our
art is a reflection of our reality you
guys supposed to be somewhere
these your artists rap is not an art you
can come down here and perhaps my
clients because of what they look like
go slow enough listen be honest with you
I don't know anything about hip-hop but
I know that you're special
be involved with this gangster life
butoh speak a little truth and people
lose their mind this isn't the Crips and
bloods this is a threat from the federal
government
what up I got something ascetic please
keep going man we can take over the
goddamn world